me encuentro a las afueras del estadio
de francia del norte de parís este
estadio a partir de este martes pues
hace oficio de megacentro de vacunación
contra el cob y de 19 una de las
estrategias que tiene el gobierno
nacional con estos centros para poder
luchar eficazmente contra la pandemia
actual las personas comenzaron a llegar
desde muy temprano a este centro que va
a atender público de 9 de la mañana a 8
de la noche para venir aquí solamente se
puede recibir la vacuna si se tiene una
cita previa ya sea hecha a través de la
plataforma de internet oa través de una
plataforma telefónica y por ahora en
francia solamente están vacunando las
personas mayores de 70 años y las
mayores de 50 años con comorbilidades
hablamos con algunas de las personas
esta mañana mientras esperaban su turno
esperamos un poco detenerle y el seguro
social también nos envía un mensaje
vemos cita la mía es para las 10 de la
mañana y como ve va avanzando y que
abrían la vacuna aquí en el estadio de
francia y esto nos permitirá volver a
tener libertad porque quiero irme de
viaje para ver a mis padres y esto no me
deja hacer nada
ayer bien la tarde por televisión que
uno podía pedir cita y logré una para
hoy a las 10 de la mañana
tengo cita para recibir la segunda dosis
luego estaré tranquila quién sabe hasta
cuándo uno de los objetivos de este
centro es administrar diez mil dosis
semanales de vacunas ya sea de moderna o
de facer por ahora las inyecciones las
hace los son bomberos y miembros de la
cruz roja y la especificidad de este
centro es que la mitad de las citas son
únicamente para los habitantes de sense
andoni este departamento que es uno de
los más damnificados por ésta
o la de la pandemia este centro estará
abierto por los próximos seis meses